let's go next to our caller from the 907
area code who is calling today from nine
one seven did I yes it is I believe so
hi David I like your shirt your cool guy
question about the opinion of you on the
impeachment hearings okay
do you find it concerning that the focus
of the public end media door / media
seems to be on the political object
rather than the fundamental shift in our
governmental principles yes I do so the
way I've been trying to say it is we can
our view over the political expediency
of impeachment we can argue over the
timing of impeachment we can argue as to
what we think the outcome will be or
whether Republicans will grow a spine
and vote to get you know we can have all
that conversation impeachment is a
process that is a duty of our elected
government if the facts warrants it and
I believe the facts warrant it and that
is much more black-and-white than all of
these considerations that are being made
about timing expediency probability for
success
they're both legitimate conversations
but I think the conversation about the
duty that exists is not getting the
attention it deserves
great that looks great
follow-up question do you have any idea
when how the media could kind of like
cuz to me as well I I see this is pretty
cut-and-dry it seems and it is apparent
to me that there were definitely
misdemeanors that occur and I don't know
the technical definition of high crimes
I would probably toss what he's done in
there as well
type rhymes but like how could the media
hold those that fall because it's not
just him accountable while not
sacrificing their viewer retention
because as we know Americans have a very
short attention span and I don't think
we would be really interested to listen
to why it's bad to listen to why what
I'm not sure I understand your question
do you think that there is a what
hello okay I didn't understand the
second question the first one was a good
one and I'm glad that it was a point
very very well made